foreign
full minute of watching fungus grow
which literally happens slower than
paint drying for what it's worth
come on asking the guy with a hole in
his abdomen for help running with a
Walkman on they'd wanted you to do that
they'd have called her to run Minnelli
also [__] PE actually [__] pee
might have been interesting so pee you
don't fight your friend's fights
she's not here anymore
what did you think was gonna happen
Bella Ramsay is just over five feet tall
you don't mess with short girls so kick
your [__] ass took a zombified giant
to kill her in the last HBO series did
you honestly think you were gonna give
her walk away unscathed to pass ahead of
you
wait is mug supposed to represent the
first path why do you think you need
visual examples to keep two things in
our minds or is it just that the
emptiness of the mug is supposed to
represent the emptiness of this speech I
can hold two ideas in my mind without
attaching them to random physical
objects Captain condescension there's a
leader in you wait I was always told
there were two wolves inside of me now
it's a leader is the leader one of the
Wolves or is the leader in there a
separate entity this metaphors are hard
at least you could have done was explain
it with a mug or something is that it
that's it I'm with Ellie here she gives
Bethany 15 stitches and your complete
responses so you're willing to obey
rules from here on out so someday you
can Lord your power over the girl you
just gave 15 stitches to yeah cool carry
on then
not giving Savage Starlight your full
interest and attention you could have
been the feige of the Savage Starlight
Cinematic Universe Ellie and you threw
it all away from the moment Riley steps
into the room she acts like she's there
to murder Ellie going so far as to wake
her up by covering her mouth in a [__]
she'll try to say she meant it to be a
joke but I looked up the definition of
joke and it didn't say anything about a
TV show needing a cheap scare so it
makes a character act completely
opposite of their own self-interest also
Ellie has plenty of time before she
knows it's Riley to call out for help
but doesn't because she is also
apparently more interested in the work
the show needs to do
also also not keeping your window locked
during the Apocalypse in my mind you
loved it well then you obviously don't
know your best friend very well you know
what kind of jokes she likes puns next
time wake her up softly and tell her one
of those at least then you won't get
stabbed actually scratch that the last
pun I told got me stabbed three times
maybe just skip jokes to be safe sort of
crazy and you're gonna say no but then
you have to say yes looks like Riley
went to the Weinstein School of
understanding consent
the fear is gone
[Music]
gone in my connections tired of taking
chances you trust me right I don't know
mysterious friend who disappears for
weeks at a time and breaks into my room
to startle me in my sleep do I trust you
I don't know should I trust you putting
your trust in someone to answer the
question as to whether or not you should
trust them it's like the TV show cliche
version of that thing where the one
guard always tells the truth and the
other one lies and then you have to ask
the right question of one of them to
know if the other one's the one that's
the liar or the truth guy I also think
there's like a melting ice block and a
horse named Sunday but I could be wrong
are they teaching you this at Firefly
University show taunts me with a firefly
spin-off where Kaylee and inara do
adjunct teaching to a bunch of Gorham
college students that will never
exists are better
grass one point for the anarchists we
prefer Freedom Fighters somehow this
episode manages to do a ton of heavy
lifting on both the emotional backstory
of Ellie by crafting a relationship we
care about and making a point about
polarization in perspective and they
didn't even charge us an extra 15 bucks
just to watch the episode
scares well technically the opposite of
jumping so drop scares is that the first
dead body you ever saw asking this
question to anyone decades into a
fast-moving fungus monster outbreak
tricked by courage no like 40 or 50.
whatever anyways old whippersnappers I
mean kids movies and shows always make
it seem like the roofs are the most
stealthy and easiest way to Traverse big
cities but roofs are all different and
often spread out they're deadly death
traps of death unless you're an obese
elderly man with a strange penchant for
reindeer you should probably avoid them
at all costs it's okay you don't know
I agree
not a weapon to use a way to end an
argument that hasn't even begun agree to
disagree is an offering you make after
listening to each other first and trying
to come to an understanding once it
becomes clear no progress is being made
it's a way to part ways his fellow
humans instead of continuing to try to
change each other's minds stop using
agree to disagree as a way to tell me to
shut up I mean someone telling someone
to shut up the mall
you out of your [__] mind the exact
thing I said to my friends every single
Friday night of my high school life
somehow makes it into the episode the
amount of electricity needed to light up
and run this entire mall would
absolutely raise some red flags
somewhere in fedra I think we're
supposed to admire Ellie and Riley
Street smarts but doing stuff like this
is more like some Street dumbs no one
can see [__] but us that long arch of
skylights begs to differ unless of
course this particular Mall chose tinted
glass for all its Windows did it
probably not tonight I'm gonna show you
the four wonders of them all old people
walking Punk kids overpriced merchandise
and an immediate headache well at least
you got one of those covered no way and
by no way do you mean no way someone
would be this Amazed by an escalator
even in an apocalypse agreed you are
just a graceful ballerina don't you mean
ballerina
see that's the exact kind of joke that
got me stabbed last time nobody gets
gutted by the end of this dumb Teen
Movie you joke but think about this for
a second what is the scenario in which
someone leaves this place and doesn't
come back but also thinks they'll be
back in five freaking minutes I'm not
saying you couldn't concoct one but I am
saying this note is more likely to read
he who is Valiant and pure of spirit can
find me in the castle of
ah Gap Kids having a bigger reaction to
an escalator than a merry-go-round
drunk driving and you might be thinking
hold on they're riding horses not a car
but you can still be arrested for
driving a horse drunk don't ask me how I
know stand and guard while people shovel
could be worse you could be the one
shoveling why didn't you tell me any of
this I don't know that's a strange way
to pronounce because these scriptwriters
thought it worked better to say it here
so the audience could really feel the
depth of the pain of it in the moment
[__] you well look at that I came
prepared charging five dollars for a
photo booth that's outrageous should be
three tops have you done this before no
idiot I was waiting to do it with you
considering all the ways this thing
could fail not testing it out first
might make you the idiot in this
situation Riley photo developing fluid
lasts 18 months in the best of
conditions that one's not bad sure but
she also did the scary pose last so why
is it third on the printouts yeah I'm
the same [__] that spent an hour
yesterday breaking this fire open
because somehow nobody else thought to
do this when she started going down and
the population was looting everything
they could smash the buttons competitive
Smash Brothers players also playing
Mortal Kombat 2 this much when Galaga is
right [__] there
choosing Raiden a second time instead of
picking someone cool like Jax Melina's
gonna kick your ass again
I mean I'll be your best friend again if
it's a dinosaur basing your friendships
on a person's ability and willingness to
pull a Jurassic Park for you what did
the frustrated cannibal do eat themself
out I may have the wrong pun book
this whole fight could have been avoided
if Riley hadn't given Ellie her birthday
gift where the [__] bombs are why do
it here dude that [__] on a table in the
food court or any other of the hundreds
of rooms inside the mall I didn't find a
small did you they posted you here ah
the show the constant gut punches well
at least I know this is the last one for
this episode tonight's my last night in
Boston this show decided to go full
rileo and Elliot and somehow I'm buying
it stupid emotions where's the freaking
hot chocolate lady when I need her
these screams will end up being a
Halloween decoration because the episode
hadn't met its fake out tension quota
yet I don't know what it was like to
have a family
to belong
I mean
thank you
in this music sucks saying the music
sucks and then proceeding to play I Got
You Babe by Sonny and Cher as if it's
not an absolute Bop this new nightmare I
get to have for the rest of my life put
your ass up here encouraging your friend
to stand on glass that may or may not
hold your combined weight
between this episode and episode 3 The
Last of Us continues to explore the
queerness of its characters in a
meaningful way that both validates
on-screen representation and doesn't
make a big deal out of same-sex
relationships one set off for handling
Ali's queerness with such respect
instead of ignoring it or using it for a
cheap gag
getting knocked the [__] out by simply
falling down
it's your celebration
or you could be forcing your best friend
to confront you as an infected and kill
you you don't know that you'll turn at
the same time just gonna add a
retroactive sand for the previous
episode where Joel told Ellie she didn't
know what losses and you might say hey
you can't add a sin retroactively and
I'll remind you that we make the rules
around here
putting an old needle that's been on the
floor in Joel's body without sterilizing
it he's got a flask with booze dip that
[__] inside first also not giving Joel
anything to bite down on but his code
sleeve in his mouth or something this
isn't Pleasant also also not offering
Joel a drink from his flask before doing
surgery that makes first aid from a
Civil War battlefield looked merciful by
comparison also times three and most
importantly using a running Stitch
instead of an interrupted Stitch
foreign
have a box of clowns let me help you out
to pass ahead of you Meryl Streep or
Madonna
dead body
close your eyes what four clothes
do you trust me yes
dude
yeah dude
let's go lesbians let's go